it was hard for me to do it wrong doing
these experiments wrong as I kept
wanting to get the mix right but I did
so maybe I'll leave a bit on the bottom
because a nice bit of woody stuff on the
bottom is a good idea shove this back on
a nice woody bass to it the easiest way
to do it just to build up sort of
roughly equal layers so covering up all
all the stuff that's in there put a bit
more in break it up a bit
it's very smelly and we don't want that
because that's anaerobic that's creating
nasty greenhouse gases you know we
really don't want that but this will now
start to take off and what I'm also
going to do is mix a bit of the fresh
stuff with it because this one's got the
right a good mix and it's also got some
fresh so that will help to kick-starting
plus it's got good organisms this one's
really nice
microorganism and worms in compost
really means a composition I'm mixing up
of composed of different elements so the
more things you can mix up with it the
better see there's quite a lot of paper
and cardboard in here liberated in Treme
now temperature is really nice the
ambient temperature is good so it's
going to keep it so if you were a novice
trying composting for the first time and
you found yourself in a situation where
things were a bit smelly it was too
moist you can still resurrect that yep
yeah we just dig it out you have to I
mean it's most pleasant job in the world
I mean it's it's all right isn't it it's
not that bad just restock it make sure
you got plenty of things that are going
to create those air channels kind of
level it off as you go so I'm not
tamping it down because this is very
solid if you've got very dry stuff what
I kept wanting to do with the dry one is
tamp it down because you don't want you
don't want so much here obviously with
this wet compacted stuff you need to
blade of a spade or shovel and breaking
up some of the things like sort of
vegetable stalks or no this is a fruit
for example yeah definitely if you've
got whole bits of fruit and veg the more
it's chopped up the better really
things like pineapple heads and broccoli
stalks which are large I mean even when
you've got
an in-vessel composter a big you know
commercial composting machine whole bits
of fruit veg you can just go through and
come out looking relatively unscathed
the other side there's a whole fruit I
mean it's it's designed there's one
whole orange it's designed to keep
bacteria out so unless you've punctured
it or split it up the battery
compartment very difficult to penetrate
into it well with my first composting
experiment I noticed there was a fair
bit of mold developing on the top of the
heap like a pin mold yeah and then on
the other hand when it's too dry it got
a bit dusty there was some sort of a
mold buildup how can you prevent that
well returning dry dusty heaps I mean
this one's not too bad actually but can
be quite dangerous because some of these
molds actually can cause a condition
called farmer's lung that's we're
assuming artists if you see a kind of
smoke pipe substance coming up on the
spores the best thing to do is to stop
water it really thoroughly either with a
rose on your watering can and then let
it settle down and then turn it because
those all those spores going into the
air in getting to your lungs can be very
very bad news there's a guy last year
wasn't never had a allergic reaction to
a spiralis feelig artists so you'd
certainly recommend if that the case and
you notice you had a dry heat then you
should wear a face mask for something
while you're treating it try and keep
your distance and apply water for the
watering can initially yeah yeah really
good though getting down near the bottom
you'll see that on the camera